je peux te dire un truc oui monsieur là
tu vas voir un challenge moi je vais te
tuer je vais proposer un challenge en
direct à 20h 1h et dorna des pmp tu vas
dire à tf1 tu vas dire j'ai vu cyril
hanouna et cyril modifs serrés qu'ils
gardent ont regardé ce que les autres
chaînes donc voilà si vous nous regardez
tf1 et chérie chèche chèche cher et très
simple tu peux faire les deux donc tu
dis j'ai vu cyril moi il faut que je
démarre la saison dès le 1er septembre
et c'est vrai le 2 septembre est-ce
qu'on va redémarrer le 2 septembre il
est ça le gêne pas que je fasse danse
avec les stars
et sinon je peux devrait pas faire cyril
voilà et ben écoute on va on va leur
dire ils vont être au courant et du
raval alors tu leur bébé il faudra trois
élections en même temps avaient regarde
le est là il est santé regarde le et met
de l'huile de jojoba il a une santé
fabuleuse de les tuer et puis à faire
conclut c'est une émission qui passe
demain il enregistre en 86 frères
d'ailleurs en 86 j'avais 16 ans sait pas
faire ça à l'émergence à vous ça vous
gêne pas d'être instrumentalisés comme
ça vous qu'être un homme libre toujours
c'est toujours un peu embêtant mais
c'est vrai que c'est toujours embêtant
mais le problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui la
télévision c'est comme ça non dans
pacino chez toi voilà chez nous tu vois
où ils peuvent tout faire
il serait alors on leur propose rien tf1
est ravi c'est sans hésiter à y aller
sur sponsorisés alors l'argent est ce
que tu veux qu'on les appelle tout de
suite oui
ah oui moi je veux bien
[Musique]
pedrazza mais appeler pedrazza [ __ ] et
donc le producteur 2 donc est-ce que
quelqu'un de tf1 va me répondre à ces
salles alors j'ai son numéro six l'a pas
changé jesson m d'eur je l'appelle tout
de suite eh ben on va voir si madame je
vais l'appeler
je vais l'appeler et on va oui président
françois dérec federer oui c'est cyril
hanouna ça va bien c'est évident ça vas
y toi mon chéri tu dis moi je s'appelle
parce qu'on est en direct on avait perdu
en chalencon là il ya un problème avec
les contrats il va être sur france 2 sur
tf1 sur ces 8 est ce que ça vous pose un
problème qu'ils fassent danse avec les
stars et touche pas à mon poste parce
qu'il va faire dans cinq les stars
pierre blanche alençon abbas il m'a dit
qu'il avait vu elle comprend pas il a le
contraint au silence à bah oui bon alors
il peut faire les deux ou pas et on sait
bien que tu vas faire dos on sait très
bien qu'il va faire danse avec les stars
people en chalencon c'est une très bonne
recrue d'ailleurs pour vous très bonne
mais on va le prendre également dans
touche pas à mon poste il va faire
également 30 millions d'amis est-ce
qu'il peut tout faire et il va peut-être
faire boule dans motus
est-ce qu'il peut tout faire ou pas ou
est ce que ça vous dérange moi ça me
dérange pas non mais parce que je parle
de tf1 bah oui bah si tu es le
producteur de danse avec les stars
donc on appelle dit le patron de tf1
coproducteur il faut qu'on appelle le
patron de défense
oui c'est vrai et encore on n'a pas de
le patron de tf1 c'est pour ça alors je
vais te dire je il ya encore un patron
dans cette chaîne fois je n'en mets
juste ses fils patois c'est qui le
patron c'est qui le patron on doit
appeler qui on doit plaire africain bon
on appelle l'art africain on tombera pas
ça non tu peux l'enlever 50% sur le
contrat il a dit ok je t'embrasse et ont
noué y rajoutez y rajoute un médaillon
napoléon
ils vous ont appelé pour faire danser
avec les stars et nous vous avez appelé
pour faire touche pas à mon poste
alors je rappelle à ceux qui nous
rejoignent on lui a dit avec l'argent tu
peux faire danser avec les stars et
touche pas à mon poste mais
malheureusement tf1 ne veut pas que vous
fassiez touche pas à mon poste et danse
avec les stars dont convient d'appeler
sa part du concert
le producteur de danse avec les stars
que vous avez vu oui le producteur de
danse avec les stars qui est très
sympathique nous a dit je ne suis pas au
courant apparemment là bas c'est la
langue de bois
apparemment vous fait peur pierre-jean
chalands sont donc je propose et je
demande aux téléspectateurs s'ils
veulent bien et au public d'appeler le
directeur des programmes de tf1
alors il ya une chance sur un million
pour qu'ils me répondent milliards mais
est-ce qu'on l'appellerait est ce qu'on
appelle le grand patron de tf1 a
réappris quand on appelle à aller je
l'appelle il n'a pas mon nouveau numéro
donc voilà peut-être ce qui est informé
je l'appelle alors attention je rappelle
à la régie parce qu'à chaque fois ils
font des plans sur mon portable donc on
voit les girondins
elle voit là alors il faut que je me
rappelle de son numéro par coeur alors
attendez attendez
voyez ce que vous pouvez me redonner
parce que ça fait longtemps que les
papes les mercis salamin castaldi s'il
voit la photo quand la nuit je peux sur
six écrans il est facile et simple il
est très sympa oui c'est bien ce que
j'avais merci alors c'est parti je la
peine je l'appelle on va voir en plus on
y est on est copains comme cochons
s'appuie depuis cinq ans à sa seule
personne à avoir valu de tête il aura
une dérogation peut-être on va
s'arranger
et peut-être que tout ira mieux avec tf1
peut-être même demain on ira faire
peut-être une soirée la bonne soirée
mousse bien une soirée mousse est une
soirée 2.5 en verve a condamné
peut-être que ils vont nous dire d'aller
nous faire [ __ ]
bien entendu parmi les bonnes réponses
arras et cyril hanouna je t'appelle en n
j'ai un deal là à te proposer un gros
deals te dirais même un big deal
ara gens ma possession
pierre-jean chalencon et avranches
alençon qui était à côté de moi
l'otage y est magnifique qui est bien
chevelu je sais que tu aimes bien les
cheveux d'argent chalencon est en passe
de signer danse avec les stars
moi je n'y vois aucun inconvénient voilà
parce que j'aime la danse et j'aime les
stars mais père jean salençon aimerait
également faire tpm pays c'est ça un
perdant champion d'arts bah oui oui bah
oui bien sûr bien sûr je pense que tant
aujourd'hui bonjour monsieur pierre
gensse et bien leur en a pris puisque
fabriqué tu connais pas son nom de
famille ça m'a aidé jamais mais je ne
sais pas mais moi il bat inquiète pas un
jeu j'essaie arabi oui donc haras si
éventuellement nous on ne voit pas
d'inconvénient
si toi tu pouvais lui donner une
dérogation dépasse également les coloris
mp par l'école voilà pour faire les deux
ça arrangerait tout le monde est
également je te le demande comme un
service tu pouvais également prendre son
salaire sur voila 2 des fal qui voit la
danse avec les stars ça m'arrangerait on
embrasse un lutin des bisous mais je
vous embrasse et d'un petit bout d'os
john duthie lecture elle offrait un truc
de napoléon ben oui je vais vous allez
venir au palais on va organiser une
soirée il ya un problème des objets de
l'empereur il va qui nouvelles fêtes et
soirées
voilà merci bon ben il va il offrira un
aigle je t'embrasse merci bon j'en ai
beaucoup
bon a priori c'est pas hyper bien non
latins kg est pas je gère sa perche orne
en soit ce que tu veux tout faire mais
oui eh bah tu feras tout allez merci
on verra ça inquiète pas on va gérer ça
ça va aller comme une lettre à la poste